I'll start off with even though I've got
the mic on my staff with the Moon adori
the hand comes up to do shaman the back
leg comes round oh he puts his hand up
to protect his face
you take it out you turn your body fully
I'll show you at both sides don't they
you cross the arms and you just do a
backward who can be nice
you can
[Applause]
the back leg
is going to turn here so
turn him
catch catch cross their elbows
down they go
I
crossed their arms cross their elbows
it's called a cloth throw that's the
this is the name of it jujinagi
ah
[Applause]
of course this one pulls out this one
Powers through with your hips you don't
need to do this very painful
ah
very painful crust and take the bottom
hand under
Cami you don't have to be you need a
good form it's okay having the fun but
you wanna
you want to be good while doing it
ah there's this one as well
there's this one
after the scene is you can cut them out
but we're going to do the
the standard one yeah
[Applause]
one two
this is what you need
but okay done what
jujinagi
it would be easy to say who's not having
a problem
uh two things I do this one for the
camera
this hand coming up here
turning makes you try and take the top
one and then you find that you've you're
restricted you it's difficult to sort of
throw them and you sometimes feel like
you're going with them even when trying
it's in this hand
so
this one goes there but this one is lift
I I step back
okay that's what done the movement now
and then you just step forward
Okay so
it's not in the first one because he
might not push back I mean he's supposed
to push back but he might not push back
so if he doesn't push back if he's here
and you go like this
then there's a big gap here
you need to sort of like
take your body back in a in a powerful
way
so it's ah see so you can't actually see
that but I'm going I'm drawing him back
and holding this one out so I'm going
like that and then
so
hey
that's what I'm doing okay so that may
help you to understand
you
this thing
because all the jujinaga is about going
back if I'd done
well we'll do this one a bit more and
then I'll show you even clear on a new
Shiro Rio cutter okay try again
that means two hands to grab the rear
now if I just put this hand out
I don't expect him to run around my back
I have to make him get there a lot of
people in Aikido clubs they they do this
and they run me on the back to catch
that's just to show the form
and that's if the sense is lazy as well
[Applause]
I must create it hand over feet
ah
I don't expect him to
I don't expect him to fall into my
attack and then me rip his head off so
you've got to uh
ah this way here
so this is to be the coaches we'll
perhaps come back to them so very slowly
so I'm here and I'm going to step one
two
okay so we just start off with this
we start off with
one two
now you have to go soft
and this
brushes here
you now need
to take the same so you need to step
back backward backward
step back
and then try
you can uh
one two
this hand here this hand on top
this is the thing that people find the
hardest thing to do is to work out where
the hand should be
hands here
one below
one on top
so it's a really nice technique for a
senior grade it's not so good for low
grade because you panic when your arms
get locked because you've got nowhere to
take your Cami
hey it's me
back here
lock the elbows
condenser
[Music]
you go down
step back lock the elbows one outline in
so
once more
don't lift it above your head
you can take back with a cameo High fall
I don't mind
ah
don't do it too quick like that a little
bit above your level
later on
your level
right under
take
back
okay please try
[Music]
so you have to build them up over the
years
and if you're prepared to do Aikido long
enough you've just got to say I can't do
it yet but perhaps next year
if you say to yourself oh I can't get
that one I've had a real bad day
then you might have a terrible day today
because I'm going to do all all
techniques that you might not be able to
do
but I don't know if you can do them or
not but then one day you're about to do
them
and then you'll feel great
and it takes time katatadori
right right
I think last year we done I showed this
hey
I'll keep checking this funny thing I'm
not used to it
[Applause]
you mowed she
you're coming out soon
[Applause]
this is Coke you Naggy
when the hips
are free there's Coke here Naggy when
the hips right they're under
and they throw up do the throwing is
koshinaki
this is Coke Q Nagy
you
your breath is running through your body
so
he's gonna touch this knee
like that
this is going to touch this knee
but because it's Coke you Naggy you've
got to do it swiftly
but that's your feeling
without that feeling you won't get it
yeah okay you don't go past them you
don't jump behind them and then forward
ah
it's like a half pound gear anybody who
knows that it's a complete turn
you offer them
you turn
we'll try and then we'll have a break
okay let's try hey